yeah
yeah yeah what's up hey know what
connect game is he playing damn central
he's not playing connect the connect
that thing that Microsoft have been
evangelizing since 2010 what panting
that never really worked the way he said
it would and say for a handful of really
fun games never really lived up to its
potential that thing that internet hate
has been targeting for what seems like
the dawn of time
yeah well Microsoft have done everyone a
solid and giving consumers a choice over
whether they want to spend their
hard-earned cash on one or not as of
June 9th you will be able to buy a
Kinect list version of the Xbox one for
$100 cheaper or 50 quid cheaper if you
live in the UK which is kind of [__]
but hardware prices in Europe are a
discussion for another day initially the
system couldn't operate whatever it
plugged in and now it seems it is a
peripheral like any other like the
PlayStation Eye or the move or the Xbox
Live vision camera before it so first of
all why well there are a number of
established truths around Microsoft's
new console which we should probably get
out of the way the Xbox one is being
heavily outsold by the cheaper
PlayStation 4 titanfall was in the
system seller Microsoft hoped it would
be the Kinect is currently very
unpopular and public perception of the
Xbox one is that it is overly expensive
because it is seemingly being
outperformed graphically by the ps4 this
decision was probably made in the past
few weeks likely once the April sales
figures came in and with magic added the
picture it seems like new Xbox head Phil
Spencer is wasting no time in trying to
get the beleaguered Microsoft console
back on tracks and let's be honest
announcing this news a month before e3
means that they'll get all the negative
headlines out of the way a month before
the biggest week in video game news
we're used to these price drops of
consoles in fact we're used to emergency
one year after release price drops with
consoles the difference is to do so the
manufacturers usually take at elements
that people actually like like backwards
compatibility or extra USB ports but
Microsoft have taken out a piece of tech
that few people are really gonna miss
and if they do they're free to buy one
separately anyway I connect this version
of the Xbox one is a good decision we
might even get an interface redesign and
some extra performance out of all this -
hooray for everyone so now that we've
established that let's look at the
flipside what does this mean for Kinect
adoption rates and what does it mean for
the future of Kinect
I'm not the biggest fan of Kinect I
always had hope for the system
I think it's genuinely useful for
navigating this horrible interface on
the Xbox one and for stuff like saving
highlights using twitch and Skype and
scanning QR codes but there's no getting
around the fact it's safe for a handful
of games like Dance Central or happy
action theater Kinect never gave us
really good reasons to play with it
perhaps I'm a victim of Microsoft
propaganda but I was still holding out
hope that we'd get some sort of really
interesting uses of Kinect this time
around Harmonix creator of the Dance
Central franchise are currently working
on Fantasia music evolved which seems to
be using the tech and exciting new ways
well it just so happened that head of
Harmonix P or John Drake was in town so
I asked them to come over and talk about
how the news is going to affect them and
the wider Kinect development community
well in exchange for 20 seconds to talk
about his amplitude Kickstarter but
we'll get to that later
first things first I think I was
standing here and hi John yeah it was it
was a little bit of a surprise but also
not people have been speculating that
might happen for a while so you kind of
roll with that punch yes it was this
something that you guys maybe sort of
had as an option that might occur some
way down the line because how many games
you developing for Kinect at this stage
we have we have a handful that we've
been prototyping or rnd and we have one
game in full-on production which is the
Fantasia music evolved which on Xbox 360
and Xbox one we've always loved making
connecting so you know I think this
doesn't really change that we still
think we can make great games so that's
assuming there's still people out there
horrible you're always going to have
less people having Kinect now because
whoever buys at least the market share
is going to it's not gonna be as going
as fast or could have been if everyone
was buying it is that a problem for you
guys and like the types of games that
you make do you need to make games and
it might appeal to a wider amount of
people so you can like drop in as many
people as possible yeah that's a good
question I mean I think we want to make
the best games for whatever input device
we're making right we are trying to be
the company making some of that great
software that hopefully makes people who
buy the foreign dollar Xbox one bundle
think like you know hey like navigating
the menus with my voice and like playing
Fantasia music evolve is a good enough
reason to pick up this camera you know
if I buy the box of June maybe buy the
camera it you know I'm Christmas or
whatever so I think it's not like it's
not like an A+ news tip for us but it's
also not it's not destructive I think
it's really about making games that
motivate people to want to buy good
games
I think player choice and consumer
choice is always a positive
so we don't look at it as a big problem
for us as much as we look at it as an
opportunity to say okay the people who
didn't buy that that camera in the box
how do we show them a game experience
it's so essential that they want to go
get that camera I feel for the folks at
Harmonix this announcement will
undoubtedly put more pressure on them at
market and you have to imagine that
other developers are a lot less likely
to try and create a game in that space
for as John said a good enough game will
make people want to buy a Kinect and
when you get right down to it that's
what this is all about that's why people
aren't rushing to the shops to buy
either console right now because the
games are in there yet and as we tiptoe
towards e3 word on the street is we're
finally going to start hearing about
games lots of games the Xbox one is more
affordable than ever and the Kinect
isn't dead but its success is entirely
connected to the games that come out for
it and in the end that's all about the
games good games sell technology and
good games consoles 24 days and Counting
20 seconds go okay amplitude is a
Kickstarter for Harmonix reviving the
2003 franchise that we made for Sony for
the PlayStation 2 we want to make it
again for the PlayStation 3 Playstation
4 up res graphics great new soundtrack
killer gameplay experience for beat
match controller based gameplay really
gotta Beckett it's a passion project for
us we need your money to make the game
please help us harmonic on such
amplitude you got three seconds on the
guy he's doing right now and say give us
money